how you doing i'm great how are you i'm
good i'm this is a dark movie you just
made
yes it's a little bit dark it's not the
typical sort of hollywood
fairy tale story by any means no not by
a long shot
what's it what's it about in like in a
nutshell this is my nutshell
version it's about four uh texan
characters who are brought together by
fate
with a slow-motion thriller underneath
this is my some of it
and a lot of really dark things happen
in the movie uh yes
you could say that is that okay when you
do a movie like that and it's is it
is it intense is it harder to do a movie
like that which is yeah i mean i haven't
had a lot of experience yet so
i don't have a huge basis for comparison
but right and you are you're yeah you're
21 is that right right wow so uh this is
must be you're working with someone like
james kahn in this movie yeah
was he what was he like uh he was great
he was
insane and great and he taught me a lot
of
things and uh it was funny because uh
i was down in texas house we were
staying in austin
and i was doing my people crossword
puzzle
college graduate ladies and gentlemen
and uh
and uh so i was doing it and uh i came
across a clue
it was uh marlon brando's character in
the godfather
so i've i've never seen the godfather i
hate to say
i know i know get off my show
i'm leaving um and one of the clues was
marlon brando's character
in the godfather so of course i didn't
know so i called jimmy
and i said um listen what's marlon
brando's character's name in the
godfather cause i don't know and he said
don corleone and i said no it's a
four-letter word ending in
o and he was like i don't know boss
capo what i don't know so so he calls me
back in five minutes and he's like
no veto it's veto and uh
you can go right to the source right at
that moment i had sort of
this realization that i couldn't believe
that i was this you know teen
like everyone else in america and uh i
didn't know
a clue in the people crossword puzzle so
i called james khan who i was doing a
movie with
uh to get the answer so it's a little
surreal yes it was when how when
did you get started real young um no i
mean i
well yes i guess i was about 17. but i
had been sort of doing it
uh my whole life a little bit in theater
right and you got well your your parents
are both
in the business that's right and uh and
they've encouraged you they've been
pretty helpful
yeah they've been great they've been
great at first they were a little
you know wary of the whole thing but now
they're very supportive and
it's very nice you did a great movie
with your mother what was the name of
that movie of the week
if you do that again so help me
god oh my god you're like my eighth
grade nun
colleagues right i wear my glasses at
the end of my nose no what was that what
did you do
oh the whole thing is falling apart okay
i'm just gonna go and
when you feel no i'm fine really i've
known jerry and ann
my whole life pretty much so they're
they're you know chiming in
okay do you have anything to add
don't get him started sad in this book
do not get him started i did i did
no no here you play with eisenhower your
hero
now are you uh are you handling this all
right i mean this is
you've made a few movies now is it are
you starting to have some of the
celebrity trappings people seeing you
recognizing you not yet but i did
use it to my advantage in the video
store the other night
uh i wanted to rent videos and um
i i didn't belong to the store so they
said you need a picture id and a credit
card and i had a credit card but i
didn't have a
a picture id uh and i looked over and i
noticed that they were selling
uh an issue of premiere which i'm in
so i said well how about this and
all right
listen uh thanks very much thanks very
much for coming by i appreciate it and
uh best of luck with the movie thanks
thanks all right we'll be
right back